[Music]
what have i been reading listening to
lately that has impacted your thinking
about parenthood well
i have something right next to me uh
and i'll just pull two books so the
first i don't even know if this has been
published yet it was sent to me by kevin
kelly who's an incredible human being
and i i still think probably the most
interesting man in the world in reality
so i would suggest listening to my first
podcast i did with kevin kelly but he
sent me this little book it's called
excellent advice for living
seeds for contemplation and these are
based on his
i want to say for the last two or three
years his annual what i've learned lists
where he turned 68 and he put together i
think 68 bullets and then he turned 69
he put together another 69 bullets and
this little book contains i want to say
between 300 and 400 of such bits of
advice kevin
is also one of the most engaged and i
would say successful
parents
and spouses i've ever seen so i find
kevin
to be a role model worth studying so
that doesn't directly answer your
question perhaps but
for me it's about understanding
someone's complete picture well enough
that you don't cherry pick one piece
and find it
later to your detriment to be hitched to
everything else right so what i mean by
that is
in the world of business for instance or
investing
i know a lot of young men make this
mistake they're like okay i want to
emulate and i'm sure young women make
this mistake or older men and women but
they'll say i want to emulate fill in
the blank investor
he or she has compounded 20 for the last
17 years
that's what i want because i want to be
rich and what they may neglect to do is
go onto wikipedia and read about this
person and realize they're on their
seventh marriage
and that you can't automatically
cherry pick
one piece of someone's life
and
force fit it into your own
and safely assume that other parts of
your life will not change
as a result of inserting that right
so in kevin's instance i feel like i
know kevin well enough we've traveled
around the world together
and i've seen him with his family i've
been to his house i've spent time with
him he's not one of my closest friends
but i know well enough to think
okay holistically
kevin has figured a lot out he also
lives in a very non-consensus way but he
does it
through reasoning and
by paying attention to his sort of
internal compass not simply to be a
contrarian so for all those reasons i
find kevin kelly fascinating and you can
certainly just look up his what i've
learned birthday posts if you can't find
excellent advice for living that's the
first one
and the next one which i've had on my
shelf for a very long time is this this
is and i think i'm going to be
pronouncing this
correctly but sorry if i'm not dear
author uh johann hari i believe it's
johan but somebody could probably
correct me if i'm wrong j-o-h-a-n-n last
name h-a-r-i this book is lost
connections and the subtitle is
uncovering the real causes of depression
and the unexpected solutions and
most of this relates as far as i can
tell now in fairness i'm only reading
part three
i'm skipping the description of all of
the causes of depression and i'm
skipping all the descriptions of the
issues and jumping straight to part
three which is reconnection or a
different kind of antidepressant and
really reading about social cohesion
and social structuring
that might be a strange way to put it
but how to think about
cohabitating
neighborhoods
community
such that
parenting among other things can succeed
so rather than saying how can i be the
best parent
which is certainly a question i'm sure
i'm going to beat to death once i get
closer to having kids
but putting that aside for the second
asking rather how can i set the
conditions
such
that
the likelihood of a kid turning out well
happy and healthy to the extent that's
possible with some genetic
determinism maybe
can i do that through thinking about
where we live
who is around us
what support structures exist and so on
so those are
two quick answers to your very short
question thank you
you